what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
marvel cinematic universe and deadpool
is coming to the mcu
we've all known this for a while but it
looks like he's going to be coming in
phase 5 or perhaps
maybe even sooner but it looks like no
later than phase
5 as deadpool is finally making moves
and we have some official reports today
that give us brand new
deadpool 3 news so we're gonna break it
all down but first if you're new be sure
to subscribe for your chance to win a
zombie hulk funko pop i'm picking a
winner next friday
so today's report about deadpool 3 is
coming from deadline.com
a very credible news outlet and they
have an exclusive report about deadpool
3 stating that marvel studios and
disney have hired the molino sisters
wendy molino and
lizzy molino to write deadpool 3 along
with ryan reynolds of course
the molono sisters are writers for bob's
burgers and even the deadpool
official account on twitter and
instagram shared this photo of bob's
burgers
with deadpool's katanas on his back
confirming the report from deadlines
stating that
deadpool has hired the molyneux sisters
to write deadpool 3.
now since they're already getting the
writers right now they are technically
in pre-production they're going to start
writing the script soon since they have
all of their writers so the script is
coming very soon and once the script is
done usually production doesn't follow
too long after
and the crazy thing is the timing of all
of this they're starting a lot earlier
than i think a lot of us
expected them to marvel hasn't even
started production on some of their
phase
4 projects and now things are already
moving for deadpool 3.
this means that deadpool is definitely
going to be coming in phase 5 but it
actually could come
even sooner if we consider the fact that
marvel studios might not actually put
deadpool in their mcu lineup there have
been reports and rumors stating that
everything that happens to deadpool
will exist in the mcu but it's kind of
going to be like
agents of shield where things that
happen in the mcu
affect the deadpool movies but things
that happen in the deadpool movies don't
really affect the entirety of the mcu
now i'm sure that's not going to be
entirely the case because i'm sure we're
going to have deadpool team up with
people like spider-man and the avengers
at some point in time they'd be foolish
not to
but it's kind of like the spider-man
movies they exist in the mcu but they're
never
included in marvel's phase 4 lineup when
they do their announcements so we could
have a similar situation with deadpool
he might not technically exist
in the lineup that marvel announces but
the movie could come out during that
time
and what that actually means is we could
actually get deadpool 3 before
phase 5 even starts but right now
there's no doubt that we're going to be
getting deadpool by the end at least
of phase 5 of the mcu phase 5 should
technically
end four or five years from now and
they're already working on deadpool
and there's no way it takes four to five
years to make this movie so
big news today marvel is making moves
with deadpool 3
and we're getting it a lot sooner than
expected in phase 5 and hopefully if
we're lucky even sooner
be sure to let me know what you think
about this awesome news in the comments
down below and let me know who you would
like to see deadpool team up with in the
mcu be sure to hit the like button and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest deadpool and
mcu news for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof